so here we are
on this topic of equality
in uh
the 21st century
so what does equality mean today
if you start to think
about this idea of equality of outcome
or the injustice of inequality
at which point does equality of outcome
is just at which point is it unjust
sort of looking at our world today and
looking at in inequality
how do we know
that some inequality is a sign of
injustice
and some is the way of life
so what does equality mean when we look
at the world today different from dr
king's speech of the basic humanity i
don't think king's speech
i have a dream that one day my four
little children will be judged not by
the color of their skin but by the
content of their character
requires
equality of outcome
he says his children will be judged by
the content of their character
that's a conditional statement
that is
the judgment will depend upon the
content of their character
not the color of their skin but it
doesn't
follow from that that the outcomes
whatever outcomes we consider wealth and
economic power
um
position within the society
representation in the various
professions uh the various measures of
social achievement doesn't follow from
judging by the content of character and
not color of skin
that when we look at the end of the day
at the social outcomes that they will be
equal across the different groups
in fact i think there's a contradiction
in the idea that groups will be equal in
all the various social outcomes that
they will be
equally successful in business that they
will be
proportionately represented in the
various professions that
they will have the same educational
achievement that the
occupational profiles will look the same
if they are in fact distinct groups with
their own cultural traditions and
practices
with their own ideals and norms
um various immigrant populations
people coming to the united states of
america from all corners of the world
the descendants of the african slaves
the
black americans here today who are
ourselves various with different origins
and so on
the different religious practices and
commitments that
jewish or
mormon or
christian or whatever
however we
parcel up
the total population into the various
groups these groups are themselves
different from one another they have
different
norms within their own
cultural practice how would we expect if
in fact we recognize that the groups are
different from one another
that in a world that is fair they would
all come out
equally represented in every undertaking
they're not
equally represented and that fact
i'm arguing is in and of itself
insufficient
to justify the conclusion
that they're not somehow being
fairly treated fair treatment doesn't
imply
equal outcomes in a world in which
the populations in question are
themselves different
with respect to their culture their
practices their norms their traditions
their beliefs their ideals
and so on the fact of those different
norms traditions beliefs
cultural orientations and ideals will
have consequences in terms of their
different
social outcomes
so i just think it's a mistake
that people are making
when they think
fairness of treatment
implies equality of outcomes it does not
is the process by which uh we're we're
speaking now
uh in the midst of the of the national
basketball association's playoffs
uh i confess to being a boston celtics
fan i mean i'm just
it's a very good team and i'm excited
about my celtics uh we defeated
the uh brooklyn
uh nets
i mean we defeated kevin durant and
kyrie irving
and company okay in a playoff series
we whipped them
and we're on our way to you know
the eastern conference finals and we're
on our way to the nba finals and i'm you
know
if i were a betting man i put down a few
bucks
that the boston celtics underrated as we
are
have a very good chance of winning the
nba finals
okay so that's the nba that's the
national basketball association i'm a
sports fan i like best slightly biased
prediction but yes
yeah it is somewhat biased
all i'm saying is
if you take a look at who the star
players are in the national basketball
association you're going to find that
there's some eastern europeans
you know there's some really good
basketball players coming out of uh
eastern europe you know
and more power to them
and there are a lot of african-americans
uh we're overrepresented
they're not that many jews as far as i
know no offense intended their lex but i
mean
the
nba
is not
equally representative of all of the
different populations in the united
states now we could go into the reasons
why but i'm just saying the process
by which you get to be playing in the
nba is fair
if you can play
you can get on the court that they all
they're looking for is people who can
play
i think something like that is true
in many different venues i expect if
you're a really good
technical
engineer
companies are going to employ you
and if you can make money
they're going to advance you and and you
will be able to
uh
rise to the top of that profession i i
expect that the people who are
uh engaged in financial transactions who
are actually making bets on the market
by and large are the people who are good
at that activity and if you're good at
that activity in this world in this
modern world
you're gonna
rise to uh rise to the top
um
i'm not saying that there are no
barriers of discrimination of course of
course there are of many different sorts
but i'm saying that to expect that there
would be
okay i mean let's look at who's actually
writing code let's look at who's
actually trading bonds let's look at uh
who's who's actually starting businesses
um and so on to say that if that in a
fair world i would expect that if black
said 10 of the population they'd be 10
of every one of those things
is to ignore the reality
that the differences in the culture and
practices and norms
of the various population groups will
lead to differences in their
representation amongst people who are
outstanding performers in
one or another
activity how do you know
if the difference in culture accounts
for the difference in outcomes
or
it's the existence of barriers
especially barriers early on in life
of discrimination that are racially
based so if you think about affirmative
action
is
in which ways is affirmative action
empowering and which way is it limiting
for these early development of the of
the different groups but let's just
speak to african-americans we should say
that
you went to some no name northwestern
university at first but then you ended
up with the great university of mit
uh so uh so that's that's your not early
but middle development
um so speaking of the development
the opportunities the equality of
opportunity
how do we know we got that equality
right
yeah i'm glad you put it like that we
were talking about results now we're
talking about opportunity i was taking a
position that
when king says i have a dream and he
envisions a world where his children
will not be
barred from
the good things in life because of the
color of their skin
we're talking about
opportunity
not about results
but opportunity is not just something
that depends upon
what the law is and what public policies
are opportunity also depends upon
the the social conditions in which
people are are are raised the social and
economic conditions so
the child of a poor
family that has no resources
it doesn't have the same opportunity as
a child of a wealthy family
to realize their full human potential
you ask me how can we tell whether or
not a
difference in outcomes
is a reflection of unequal opportunity
or it's a reflection of differences in
culture and interest and and practice
and i don't know that there's a single
answer to that question but i think
one wants to look at the data one one
wants to try to
measure
you know as a social scientist i would
say you what you want to do is you want
to estimate
the
uh
the significance of various factors for
determining the outcome if the outcome
is
how much money does a person make when
they work in the labor market so you
look at their wages
and you think well that depends upon a
number of things it depends upon how
educated they are what kind of skills
they have what kind of work experience
they have
and so on and those things are all
legitimate factors
that might determine how much they end
up making in the labor market
but you also want to perhaps con
controlling for those things see whether
or not
the fact that they are black or they are
latino or whatever the fact that they
are male or that they are female
uh the fact that they do or do not speak
english as their native language this
kind of thing whether those
factors also
are implicated in determining
uh how successful they are in the labor
market and if you find that
after you have
controlled for the things that are
legitimately
determining
uh success and failure in the labor
market like skills and education
and experience having controlled for
those things the fact that a person is
black or is
a woman or is an immigrant or
is of
of a
latino
background
also
affects their earnings then you might
conclude that to that extent
they are not getting equal opportunity
labor that kind of idea
but i want to focus
a little bit more here
on what we mean by opportunity because
it's not just
whether employers
treat the worker
on a fair
and even basis irregardless of the
workers racial or ethnic background
that's one
opportunity issue but that's how that's
at the end of the development
process they are now
presenting themselves to the market
trying to find work
and being employed at this or that wage
that's the end of the line
what about the developmental opportunity
the opportunity to acquire skills in the
first place
that goes all the way back that goes all
the way back to birth it even goes back
to before birth
um
the mother
carrying the infant in the womb
she has certain nutritional
uh
practices and she might be smoking or
drinking alcohol or something like that
i'm not saying she is i'm not saying she
is and i'm just saying whether
she is so she is and it will affect the
development of the fetus uh the newborn
uh now there's a question of environment
uh there's a question of the development
of their
uh neurological uh potential uh do they
learn how to read uh do uh are they
stimulated verbally how many words have
they heard spoken uh
are they uh being uh nurtured in a home
environment so as to maximize the
possibility of them achieving their
human potential
what about the peer group influences
what about the
values and norms of the surrounding
human communities in which they're
embedded do they encourage the young
person to apply themselves
uh in a systematic way
to their studies and to their uh focus
on their
acquisition of language command and of
their
educational potential
uh so development
is not only something that
is controlled by
the society's practices it's also
something that is influenced
by the the cultural background
of the individual and those things are
not
equal
uh those things vary across
uh groups in in a very uh significant
way and that too will be a factor uh
determining disparities of outcome
so when i see outcomes that are
different
i see wealth holding uh that's different
i see educational achievement that's
different i see representation in the
professional schools in law school and
medical school that's different between
groups
one question is are the institutions
treating people fairly but another
question is
do the background in social and cultural
influences equip people
uh in the same way
and we know that the answer to that not
in every instance do they equip people
in the same way and so it makes the
judgment the moral judgment that we make
when we see inequality of outcome
complicated
inequality of outcome is a systemic
factor to some degree
but it is also
a cultural factor to some degree
i want to say and now that's
controversial i know
uh a lot of people
they think of themselves as being
progressive
uh they they want to
point a finger at society whenever they
see a disparity
but i think that that's a mistake i
think it misunderstands
the the uh
difficulty of the problem
you think that if you get the right law
uh if you have the right public policy
uh if the right politicians are elected
to office suddenly those disparities
will go away
and um i'm here to tell you that uh that
that's uh a false hope
um
and and moreover it
is probably the wrong goal
you